hi everybody and welcome to our preview
of capital one's the match
champions for change i'm brian anderson
your host and
joining us via cisco webex our four
competitors this year
we've got the two hall of famers phil
mickelson and charles barkley
and the two future hall of famers peyton
manning and stephen curry guys
thanks for being with us looking forward
to watching all of you play or maybe
at least watching three of you play golf
coming up november 27th friday after
thanksgiving
gonna raise a lot of money the primary
beneficiary hbcus historically black
colleges and universities
and we're going to be providing a bunch
of meals as well we're already
basically nearly six million dollars
into the charitable
contributions we haven't even started
yet so this should be a lot of fun now i
want to go around the horn here talk to
everybody really quick
phil want to start with you this is your
third time around with
the match you've been a part of all of
them now we're going to your home course
a place you
love so much you bought tell us about
stone canyon tell us about your
expectations
uh for the match the third version
champions for change
as i look at peyton i can't help but be
envious and jealous of the fact that he
won the last match and so
i took it away from his partner's home
course and
brought it to a course that i own and
have a little bit of
knowledge and understanding on because i
want i want the title back and i i
upgraded my partner
i brought in sir charles and uh feel
like
we're ready to go and stone stone canyon
is this beautiful setting that's going
to be challenging for
players of steph and payton's skill
level but i think charles and i are
going to be just fine on it
and you'll be playing for uh jackson
state charles
my first question to you is why on earth
would you leave that
cushy booth gig next to me and trevor
emelman and
want to go play golf in this scenario
man i mean
i thought we had a good thing going
there in florida
well let me tell you something it's an
honor and a privilege to play with these
three guys
first and foremost uh and listen are we
gonna raise a lot of money
for a great some great charities uh
but you know brie i got to pick uh pick
a little poem with you
you said uh number one i'm blessed to be
in the hall of fame
and phil's in the hall of fame how do
you know steph and peyton gonna get in
the hall of fame
confident man peyton payton's going in
this in 21. i feel it
we don't know
[Music]
you know that's what we do we don't
stick with the facts in my line of work
we just kind of we throw a lot of stuff
out there
and just you know we make it up as we go
who are you playing for in the event
charles give us uh
give us your college i'm playing for
tuskegee
uh you know ba i'm really concerned
about a lot of these schools i've been
involved with morehouse and clark
in atlanta in miles college and alabama
afm and birmingham and i just added
tuskegee to my portfolio
so i'm just excited man and uh because
it's all it's a little down
the street from auburn so i've been
there many times and i can't wait to
raise a ton of money for them
oh very cool all right peyton you're up
next um
so you're the defending champ phil
mentioned that you're you're trading
tiger woods for stephen curry
uh your expectation level coming in i
thought you've
you played great in the last match in
the driving reign uh you and stefan are
pretty formidable you two are the
favorites
right now according to draftkings
well this will be our first uh time
playing together
uh stephanie i've never played golf
together and like phil
said he brought it to his home course
where he designed it
knows all the nuances knows where the
where to hit the ball steph and i are
not going to have a caddy
so we are going to be totally on our own
the entire time
i am i'm a little concerned about
playing with steph uh
steph doesn't really know what alternate
shot is because he never alternates who
shoots
on the court he shoots every time so am
i gonna get to play
i'm not sure but you know what i'm fine
with that if he wants to hit every shot
let's do it our chances are probably
better if he does
but uh it's an honor to be back it's an
honor to be asked
by phil and all the people that started
the match
to be a part of this raise 20 million
dollars last time for coded relief and
as you said the beneficiaries are uh
hbcus this year uh which is a tremendous
cause and
it's going to be fun to be a part of it
again to compete with steph and
to watch phil do his craft and to try
not to watch
charles i think would be a challenge for
steph and i to kind of
block our vision as he's hitting i think
mentally that's the right way to
approach it
peyton tell us the three schools you're
going to be applying for
not just one you're taking on three
there in louisiana
yeah splitting some of the money raised
through this match
to start scholarships for deserving
student at lane college in tennessee
southern of new orleans uh suno as it's
known as
in new orleans and grambling state
university so
honored to partner with those three
schools and to try to help a deserving
student
uh take a little burden off of hit up
off of him or her
that's outstanding all right stefan
you're new to the game
we're glad you're here welcome to the
match
family you've been watching from afar
what made you want to be a part of this
and participate
i think we're all excited to see how
your game holds up with these uh with
these other competitors
oh yeah i was watching the match too
just kind of taking it all in you know
watching peyton just
surprise everybody with his uh his
talent out there on the course
phil just trying to do you know whatever
he could with his partner early in the
round and keep him motivated i feel like
he's gonna have to do a lot of that
uh come next friday so he's got some
reps that's good
uh but i i you know how much i love golf
um competing you know all over the
country just trying to play as much as i
can and raise awareness
of how much i love the game so this is a
cool opportunity i think i
i petitioned pretty hard uh sending out
that tweet during the match too like hey
i went in
and now we're here so uh the one thing i
am
you know a little concerned about is is
phil's intimidation
uh strategies uh i'm looking at his
frame right now
and that's just that's just ridiculous
and i don't know if he's trying to send
subwoome
i have a bookshelf back here but i got
nothing on it so uh
i i missed opportunity i missed the
opportunity
stephan uh
look at this look at look at what coach
pure sent me
yeah that's big right there howard
you're gonna
you're gonna play for them i
am i'm playing for howard bison i was
fortunate to be a part of bringing their
division one golf program back
uh made that commitment last year and uh
obviously with cove and everything
things got a little bit delayed but
we're looking forward to the spring to
hopefully getting them
out on the course and starting uh you
know their their journey as a program
and
so we're playing for howard you know
coach perrier who's there we got a lot
of talented
men and women golfers that are in the
program and and
just trying to create as many
scholarships and and lead towards an
endowment that'll keep the program
around
forever so uh excited to uh to play for
them and hopefully raise a lot of money
all right well again it's it's going to
happen the friday after thanksgiving um
guys just i want to bounce around a
little bit with with format so it's
going to be modified alternate shot on
17 of the 18 holes there will be a
scramble hole
um and that's going to be interesting so
phil you you've kind of developed a
little bit of the the style of play now
at the match
two uh the one we did in memorial day
the alternate shot was
on the back nine and you and uh you and
tom had a great run
had an amazing nine holes on that uh
alternate shot so maybe
tailored out a little bit uh to your
game you and charles i'm i'm curious to
see how much desert time you're going to
get
with charles on the alternate shot
format
well i'm not unfamiliar with playing out
of the rough out of the desert so i i
don't that doesn't scare me off
my partner my partner uh
he he knows how to play the game when i
played with charles first time back in
the 90s when he was on the phoenix suns
he shot in the 70s every round he hit
the ball solid with no
no issues whatsoever and i we're gonna
we're gonna
dig deep and bring that game back
and i think we're gonna win by kind of a
large margin so my biggest concern is
more
i don't want it to end too early like i
don't want to close them out six and
five and not make it interesting
exciting for the fans so
uh we we we we certainly are concerned
about that
but uh you know from a game standpoint
my man
and and my man can pot my man can play
he's got soft hands a great touch on the
greens
and if i can get the shots around the
cactus
and onto the green like we're gonna be
we're gonna be in good shape
charles you got a membership there at
stone canyon yet i mean how many
practice rounds have you put in
at this point i've been there twice
to practice get practice rounds in and
i'm going up
one more time with the great gary mccord
one of my neighbors in arizona cannot
wait to get up there again
uh the guys up at stone canyon been
amazing i played with coach loy
uh last uh last week uh so i'm really
looking forward to it man i'm gonna have
a great time
and i will say this if i don't play well
i'll be very disappointed
i have hit balls for at least a minimum
five hours a day
and i played every single day for the
last month if i don't play well
i'll be i'll be number one i'll be
disappointed
uh because i don't want to let phil down
uh and listen uh you know
payton i just got to make sure he got my
phone number he texts me all the time
but
since tennessee hasn't won a game it's
been a few weeks since he texted me
it's been more of a it's been more of a
mental strategy by steph and i
not to text our opponents uh we just
wanted to kind of
get our game faces on and uh you know
that's kind of news to me that charles
has played
has been to stone canyon three times um
he hasn't played golf he's just gone
there to eat three times they have great
lunch and dinner service so this would
be his first time playing the course
in the actual match on friday so i feel
a little better of that
i think the one thing that uh didn't go
unnoticed by me and i saw
steph kind of react is in phil's opening
comments saying that he
upgraded his partner now if i'm a
certain quarterback down in tampa i
don't know how
to take that you know charles i know
he's trying to create some
confidence in his partner but uh i mean
charles
you know in that cushy booth ripping on
tom and now
i see tom tweeting a little bit during
this match especially if charles
finds one of those uh finds a piece of
desert or a cactus
that he's by i see a certain tweet
coming out of one tom brady
tell us a little bit about the course
and where you think
some of the strategy will come and play
i know there's a couple of drivable par
fours
uh you guys are going to play different
t's on some of the holes
and i think charles they may just place
him on the green a couple of times is
that kind of how it's going to go down
or
what plan for charles on these
at stone canyon we actually have chuck
tees
some people refer to them as ladies
tease but i call them chuck t's or
they're
up i know a little bit uh
further up
but the the the chorus is actually
pretty penalizing in spots because of
the desert
but it's also got a great mixture of fun
holes
like drivable part fours reachable part
fives great mixture of length off the t
on the par threes our our sixth hole is
a
spectacular part three with waterfalls
and such that's only
about a wedge but it's a very demanding
shot uh i'm uh
i i actually i i feel like charles is
better adapt
on the the green on that hole so if i
can hit the green and let him putt that
would be that's our strategy on that
same thing on the drivable par fours we
saw what happened in match two
where we were really getting uh beat up
pretty good and then
tom and i on 11. i drive the green and
he rolls the putt in for eagle and it
just turns the whole match up
uh the other way we we get all the
momentum and and really should have won
that match i mean
there were a couple of things down the
stretch i mean peyton's iron shot on 16
to three feet i
i don't know i don't know if that that
was uh legit
or not i don't know what happened there
i missed something i couldn't see the
green i couldn't see
that far up the rain and somehow his
ball is three feet from the hole when
it's all said done i
i don't know i question that but so so
i don't want to like uh you know file
lawsuits and like try to
you know question the outcome or any of
that stuff but
i do have a question on that one
yeah so we are gonna have spotters i'm
gonna have
you know spotters from my camp make sure
that anytime we have a blind shot we're
able to
to to see the opponent where the ball
goes uh
tracking them in the desert what not but
uh
there's a great there is a great mixture
in all seriousness of of
spectacular uh clubs and shots
throughout your bag
like you're not gonna hit the same club
over and over uh and
certainly with charles and my partner i
won't either
stefan i know you played with phil in a
a pro-am on the pga tour you've competed
uh i think you competed as an amateur
but you played in
what is now the corn fairy tour i mean
you've kind of been in the fire a little
bit and i know
peyton you've played in a number of
programs throughout your career so give
me
stefan give me a little idea of your
mindset going into this event
you know it's you're gonna we've been
wearing a microphone an earpiece
it's gonna be a lot of banter going on i
know you can talk trash because i've
heard it down on the floor
are you going to be able to translate
that uh to the with these alpha dogs and
the golf the golf game for sure
i mean that's the benefit of playing you
know in front of 19 000 people every day
you can handle noise and distractions
even on the golf course so bringing that
uh
that element of experience the one thing
i do have to ask about
you know if there's a rules committee or
a board of governors or somebody that i
can protest
the spotters that phil is going to place
on the course that's like bringing
your own refs to a playoff game i don't
understand how that works so
peyton we gotta find you know some some
eligible candidates to put in the field
ourselves
make sure you know we count all the
strokes
so uh that's uh that's big but i think
uh
yeah i'm excited between me and peyton
point guards and quarterbacks there's a
lot of chemistry and a lot of
similarities there of how we see you
know a particular game particular whole
particular scenario
and being able to kind of react on our
feet so
you know hopefully we hit a lot of good
shots i've seen peyton play obviously
uh in the match too and i know it's in
there phil that was not a coincidence
that's pure skill
um so i'm ready to i'm ready to ride
that train all the way to a victory
nice peyton uh give me some thoughts
about
uh doing this again second time around
how you enjoyed the first one you
competed in and then now
now we're here for uh the champions for
change version of this one
well my mindset is very similar is to
is to try to put steph in the best
position you know when i was playing
with tiger
trying to hit the best shot i could to
give him just any
chance of hitting it to the green and so
it's kind of the same approach with
steph i haven't played with him but i've
seen his game he's got all the shots
and uh i'm looking forward to kind of
watching him do his thing so hopefully i
can
drive the ball better than i did last
time and give him a chance maybe to hit
that second shot up there
close close to the hole for a little tap
in
tap in birdie the weather phil
has as promised will be better it will
not be a monsoon this time
in arizona so that'll be good
i think there will be some blind shots
all day because it will be hard to see
around
charles where the ball went so there
will be some
there will be some blind shots uh that's
that's that's all
just to admit that it's going to be a
lot of fun
there's no question about that look
phil mickelson's one of the greatest
competitors of all time i can see the
look in his eyes right now
he is focused he is ready how he thinks
you know charles is an upgrade you know
i'd probably question
phil's gm skills on an nfl team like the
chargers this year brian
they're going to have a they're going to
have a high pick in the draft right we
pretty much know that right
the idea is they're going to try to
draft someone that's going to help
them improve next year and so for phil
to draft charles i'd like to know
what went into that process what
criteria he was looking for and how he
landed
charles barkley as his draft choice
go ahead phil so so that's actually an
easy one to answer
because as i assess our opponents
i i find that peyton the thing that you
do so well in golf is that
you play within yourself like you know
your limitations in golf
you don't try to play outside you you
hit solid shots keep the ball in play
and you advance it forward and you're i
noticed in match 2
how you didn't try to get out of your
element and i noticed that when i played
with steph
he has a professional caliber game he
has all the shots the ability to shape
it each way and he
and we played on a tour caliber course
so i know the quality of our opponents
what i found though was peyton is that
the way
to win is to get both of you
out of your element and there's nobody
better at that than charles
he knows what to say and how to say it
at the right time
to get you out of your element and i
have a feeling in fact i know
that you're going to try shots
that you shouldn't and that's how we're
going to end up winning we're going to
have you
mess up much more so than we're going to
have to outperform
i get it i get that now i get that i
think that'll be
that'll be a challenge for steph and i
not to listen and not to watch
anything that charles does
yeah you know tom was very complimentary
of you peyton he's very complementary of
tiger he's very he was very
very nice throughout uh he didn't
intimidate
he wasn't trying to intimidate and try
to like hit crazy drives or do anything
and and so you felt very comfortable you
were relaxed you played within yourself
and you had a great day and you ended up
winning a close match one up again i
still uh questioned
a couple of the shots and you know
throughout the round but
i i know charles charles is is going to
be
he's going to be more attacking like a
very subtle needle
uh but again at the right times and he
just knows how to get
people uncomfortable and
it's that talent that he has that is
going to give us the upper hand
i don't know charles give me last word
here we're gonna
we're gonna uh everybody can jump in too
but i'm calling it the chuck nato
the chuck nato is coming gary mccord
trevor
been killing me today i just can't wait
till friday uh because i'm going to play
well
me and my partner go ham and eggette
we're going to play fantastic
i want these guys to go to the gulf
dictionary and look at the word
dormie uh get used to that word
dormie so you'll probably be dormie
around 14 if we play if we bring our a
game if i bring my my decent game
yo guys get used to where you guys gonna
be dormie
around 14. go look up what that means
dormie
that that big word you used if man we're
not even going to be able to hear your
trash talk from the chuck keys though so
it's not even going to make a difference
be like we can't hear you way up there
what do you say what are you even saying
awesome man i can't wait to to get this
going appreciate everybody being a part
of this one
we had great fun uh the last two have
been outstanding
everybody's gonna be wearing microphones
we'll have cool technology
and uh we can't wait to see you guys
perform and entertain and we're all
looking forward to it thanks for doing
this for us
and we'll see you guys on the golf
course day after thanksgiving appreciate
it
yes sir thank you thank you thank you